i'm damona hoffman the resident love
expert of the drew barrymore show and
valentine's day is coming or what i call
peak season in the biz and i'm going to
tell you some red flags and green flags
of romance
[Music]
red flag that actually happened to me my
first valentine's day with my husband
but it's okay he ended up making dinner
for me and it was even more romantic
maybe i should make that a green flag
actually
red flag if you've been dating for a
while and they don't ask you for
valentine's day plans they're either
broke or they're with somebody else i
would say after about three or four
dates you should be spending valentine's
day together or
just suspiciously out of town
red flag you shouldn't be criticizing
anything that your partner loves support
them support the valentine's day
lives
we don't do it in my household
for obvious reasons every day is
valentine's day
right that's what i meant
oh that is a red flag if they had
valentine's day plans
that's when you cut it off just
just from jump
red flags if you get a lot of gifts for
valentine's day and you just started
seeing one another they are probably
trying to prove something it's a little
bit too much too soon
green flag because like it's true right
are you a fan of uh
rom-coms yeah i'm a fan of drew i'm not
a fan of rom-coms because it makes my
job harder people come in with
unrealistic expectations that i have to
unravel it's a lot more work for me
sorry drew i guess drew barrymore really
fuels your business in a big way thank
goodness for drew barrymore because now
i have all these hopeful romantics that
i can help find dates for
oh um that's a green i don't really like
chocolate you are a wild guy
oh red flag red flag you want specific
gifts that speak to the person that
you're with not something generic
although i told my husband he didn't
like flowers one year and so now like he
never gives me flowers and now i see
other people getting flowers i'm like
can you give me some flowers at least to
put on instagram
look that's just how it is that is just
how we do
you can say your mom's your valentine
you can give her some of those little
candy hearts or chocolates but your
mom's not your romantic valentine k no
it's like twice as expensive you're
setting yourself up for disappointment
don't do it
tell us your red flags in the comments
and happy valentine's day